hey guys I'm Dave Batista and I'm Kemal
Nanjiani and we are here at BuzzFeed to
read thirst wheels my boyfriend just
referred David Bautista as a sexy Dorito
and to be honest he's not wrong we
wonder held that conversation woman's a
sexy dureena
Oh Emma's on the boyfriend said to
another boyfriend yes gotcha
you know emissions cuz it's you got the
V the tapir yeah that's what it is you
like dude you love me yeah okay sex
dream about Kumail Nanjiani last night
there was cheese of flat-screen TV
involved and we both died at the end not
using his handle it was a sex dream that
was cheese and a flat-screen TV not that
it died there's so much detail in that
and I don't know how any of it connects
well I'm off dairy right now so that
would explain why cheese would kill me
the way you spell sexy is dave bautista
hashtag damn it's true she's bad at
spelling but she has good taste in men
Jameel now johnny is v sexually and the
rest of you are just going to have to
deal with that was that very yeah very
when was she I don't know because
there's clearly enough letters to go go
around and it's V period and no other
punctuation and the rest of the thing
it's like that would be like a curse
word or something yeah it's [ __ ] sexy
[ __ ] Camila China's [ __ ] sexy at
Dave Bautista I know you are so busy I
just want to dip you in chocolate and
lick it off I like that it's so like I
know you're really busy right fine I'll
get him fat of chocolate lick it off
it's saved time by just keeping the
chocolate camille Nanjiani has a nice
butt true it's just an observation
factual statement it's tight and perky
we had a conference we had a whole
conversation about your book I show but
in the movie
when you're on the swing ha that was a
tough thing for my parents didn't go
well I got a heads-up from my dad that
was like just so you know my mom is very
disturbed
on another note Dave Bautista is one
sexy mother the height the muscles and
the tattoos hashtag UNF hashtag DILF
you know what delft is what is hashtag
UNF oh maybe it's the noise that you
make like oh do tell
I'll take it thanks on officially
proclaiming command Nanjiani to be a
bonafide sex symbol
ooph ID I will I will take no for an
asset at this time meaning that is that
is not up for discussion with ali-a that
her job 10 sheep officially proclaim sex
symbols like is that a power she has I
want to lick Camille not Jionni's brain
now that is not done as I said as a
compliment it's a compliment but it's
like oh yeah no I don't want people to
think I'm smart I want people to I don't
want nobody to lick my family they do I
have never gotten I want to lick they
play the only part of my body I don't
want lick I'll take everything else I
would take a good brain looking at
Camille and Johnny is so sexy I can't
even deal self should try dealing with
it dave bautista I'm good deadlift me
and that's extremely sexy you could
better lift most people I would think
hundreds of pounds rather have my brain
licked but easy command on Johnny I
don't want to get in the way of your
beautiful marriage but please me please
me if that will get in the way of my
beautiful marriage that will probably
wouldn't be a good thing easy pretty
easy for me daddy
lead daddy why does come on does he
always look like you just smacked his
girlfriend's ass you know the smirk I'm
talking about I mean that's sexy
8f though I always look like I just
smacked my girlfriends after just make
all right now I just like that yeah it's
a Kathleen who ate the canary Smurf Oh
Kemal not Jionni's eyebrow raised as my
sexual orientation
yeah take that take that Jordan take you
just take dave bautista
take me into your arms and give me a big
hug challenge what's the big hug
challenge mm-hmm you just question I
don't know I think no one I've became
synonymous with hugs after guardians to
do you think you could hug someone and
break the ribs
I'm not into chewing with no punch bowl
yeah Wow super excited or emotional or
angry luan so blue wants a big hug
challenge all right no here we go I'd
call Kumail Nanjiani daddy hot damn
see this daddy thing it's still
unsettling you know why cuz they called
my actual dad I started calling him bad
recently but growing up I'm teddy
it's IB yes so you're like 35 no like
actual I stopped a while ago before the
ultimate elegance daddy yeah we called
him Danny so did he tell you to stop
calling him dead no I just got like oh I
think the word the way this word is
being used is morphing and I don't want
any part of it why does it sound so when
you ask me that maybe it's just weird
coming out of my mouth
you're saying it is like oh that's it
okay Wow
that's a dirty well that was super fun
these guys yeah good for both our egos I
assume live for money yeah yeah what are
you talking about nobody wants to lick
my brain now go see stupor it opens
watch whoo
goodbye boys for you thank you
[Music]